>> AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
HE'S REPLACING V.A. SECRETARY
DAVID SHULKIN.
HE PINNED FAREWELL IN THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
HE MADE THE PLACE BETTER AND
SERVED HIS COUNTRY AND NO ONE
LIKES TO BE FIRED.
I SHOULD KNOW, THREE TIMES.
I GOT ONE BEEF.  HE CLAIMS HE
WAS FIRED BECAUSE HE OPPOSED
PRIVATIZING THE BUREAUCRACY.
CLAIMING THE PRIVACY SECTOR
COULD NOT HANDLE THESE PATIENTS.
IT'S WHAT ENABLED THE V.A.
TRAGEDY IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE DIFFERENCE WAS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE FREE
MARKET THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES TO
ACTIONS.
IF YOU SUCK, YOU SUFFER.
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR, THERE'S NO
REAL COSTS TO YOUR BLUNDERS
WHICH IS WHY WHEN THINGS ARE
BAD, IT TAKES YEARS TO FIX THEM.
LIKE THE V.A.
WHERE THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY,
THERE ARE STANDARDS.
IT'S ONE BUILT ON COMPETITION
WHICH REWARDS THE COMPETENT AND
PUNISHES ITS OPPOSITE.
THE MARKET WORKS FASTER IN
ERADICATING PROBLEMS BECAUSE IT
CAN'T PUT OCCUPY WITH THEM.
SHULKIN DID A GOOD JOB.
HE DID A GOOD JOB AFTER A REALLY
BAD JOB BY BUREAUCRACY IMMUNE TO
COMPETITIVE PRESSURE.
BY BASHING PRIVATIZATION WITHOUT
PROOF, HE DEFENDS THE SYSTEM
THAT'S NOT AS GOOD AS HE IS.
MAYBE LET'S TRY A NEW APPROACH
IF IT DOESN'T WORK, AT LEAST THE
FREE MARKET WON'T TRY TO HIDE
IT.
DANA, I THINK SHULKIN DID DO A
GOOD JOB.
HE WAS STARTING LESS THAN ZERO
AT THE V.A.
LET'S SAY YOU BECOME COACH OF
0-16 NFL FAMILY AND YOU GET TO
3-13.
>> THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX
PROBLEM.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR DECADES.
EVEN DIS-- DISAGREEMENTS BETWEEN
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND V.A.
THIS QUESTION ABOUT
PRIVATIZATION IT'S ALARMING.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT A VETERAN
WHO MIGHT LIVE IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY AND DOESN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO IMMEDIATE NEAR
HOSPITAL, VA HOSPITAL.
SHOULD THEY BE ALLOWED TO HAVE A
PRIVATE VOUCHER TO GO AND GET
TREATMENT AT THE NEAREST
HOSPITAL RATHER THAN HAVING TO
TRAVEL SO FAR.
OR IT HAPPENS A LOT, THEY FOREGO
TREATMENT.
I DO THINK THAT INNOVATION HAS
BEEN STYMIED FOR DECADES.
HE WAS NOT LET GO BECAUSE OF THE
PERFORMANCE AT THE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS QUESTIONABLE BEHAVIOR IN
REGARDS TO BEING IN THE NEWS
ABOUT HE HANDLED AFTERWARDS
TRIPS OVERSEAS WITH THE WIFE AND
ALL THAT.
IT WAS JUST GETTING TO BE TOO
MUCH TO BEAR.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
IT SAYS ABOUT INNOVATION.
IN PUBLIC AGENCIES, WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY,
INNOVATION IS SLOWED.
ACCOUNTABILITY IN GENERAL
PREVENTS QUALITY FROM COMING TO
THE FLOOR.
DO YOU AGREE IN SOME WAY SHAPE
OR FORM?
>> I THINK WHAT YOU SAY IS TRUE.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR TENDS TO BE
MORE PUNISHING FOR FAILURE.
WHAT I I THINK WE'RE OVERLOOKING
HERE, DANA TOUCHED ON IT, THIS
IS NOT A NEW DEBATE.
PRIVATIZATION HAS BEEN A LONG
TERM DISCUSSION WITH REGARD TO
HOW WE TREAT OUR VETERANS IN
TERMS OF MEDICAL NEEDS.
WHAT'S COME UP IN THE DEBATE,
IT'S BEEN A FULL THROATED
DEBATE, IS THAT, OFTEN TIMES
VETERANS ARE SUFFERING FROM
THINGS LIKE POST-TRAUMATIC
STRESS OR THEY'RE HAVING BRAIN
INJURIES OF A THAT ARE ARE
SUFFERED ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
THE V.A. DEVELOPED
SPECIALIZATIONS HOW YOU HANDLE
THESE ISSUES.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR DID NOT HAVE
AN INCENTIVE BECAUSE IT'S HOW
MANY SUCH SITUATIONS DO YOU SEE
IN ORDINARY LIFE.
BY THE WAY, DANA, WITH REGARD TO
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN RURAL AREAS
FROM VA HOSPITAL, ETHIS ALREADY
GIVE OUT VOUCHERS.
WHAT YOU HAVE NOW IS A SITUATION
ACCORDING TO SHULKIN, WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OF A MIND
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
PRIVATIZATION.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
THE ARGUMENT OR THE DEBATE.
SHULKIN WRITES IN HIS OP ED THIS
IS ABOUT PURSUING A POLITICAL
AGENDA.
HE NOTES BY THE WAY, HIGH LEVELS
OF RIGHT NOW APPROVAL FROM
VETERANS FOR THE V.A., I THINK
HE SAID 70%
>> KIMBERLY MY POINT TO THAT, IT
WAS SO BAD WHEN HE TOOK IT OVER,
ANY IMPROVEMENT WILL BE TAKEN AS
WELCOME RELIEF.
>> IT WAS JUST ABYSMAL IN TERMS
OF THE ABUSES HAPPENING.
IT'S A STILL VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM THAT THEY HAVE WITH THE
V.A. AND ADMIRAL TAKING IT OVER
NOW IS REALLY GOING TO HAVE A
TOUGH TIME.
THERE'S SO MANY ABUSES THERE AND
CORRUPTION.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO TERMINATE
ANYBODY MORE LACK OF COMPETENCE.
HE'S GOING TO BE STUCK WITH TIME
TO REBUILD AND REHABILITATE THE
CULTURE AT THE V.A.
HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
IF HE WINS THE CONFIDENCE OF THE
PEOPLE THERE, HOPEFULLY THEY
WILL BE EMBOLDEN AND THE
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT TO HELP THE
VETERANS.
THEY REALLY DO DESERVE OUR VERY
BEST.
>> JESSE LAST WORD.
MAKE IT COUNT.
>> OKAY.
I WOULD SAY THAT CABINET
SECRETARY IS NEVER GOING TO BE
ABLE TO FULLY CONTROL A
BUREAUCRACY.
THEY CAN ONLY SEEK TO TAME IT
AND IN TERMS OF SHULKIN, HE DID
AN AVERAGE JOB.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
THAT HAPPEN WHERE THEY HAVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PROTECTION SO
YOU CAN FIRE AND DISCIPLINE BAD
APPLES WITHIN THE V.A.
ALSO AS JUAN SAID THEY EXPANDED
THE MENTAL HEALTHCARE FOR
VETERANS RETURNING OVERSEAS THAT
PREDISPOSED TO SUICIDE.
BUT THE ETHICAL LAPSES WERE
TROUBLING.
HE'S TAKING HIS WIFE ON A
EUROPEAN SITE SEEING AND
SHOPPING TOUR THEN LIED ABOUT
IT.
HAD TO REIMBURSE SIX FIGURES.
LAST YEAR, LAST MARCH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND THAT THE
V.A. WAS LYING ABOUT WAIT TIMES.
THEY SAID IT'S 36% RATE THAT THE
VETERAN HAS TO WAIT.
THEY LIED AND SAID IT WAS ONLY
10%.
THEN ABOUT $13,000 IN VIRGINIA,
GOT THE CHOICE PROGRAM.
YOU GET TO GO TO A PRIVATE
HOSPITAL.
THEY NEVER LET THEM GO TO A
PRIVATE HOSPITAL.
THEY HAD TO WAIT THREE MONTHS.
THAT'S LAST MARCH.
THIS MARCH, SAME THING.
THE AUDIT FOUND THE SAME THING.